on to other news in the hong kong media
tycoon jimmy lie has been
detained this is the most high profile
arrest yet
under the new beijing imposed national
security law lies among seven
people arrested on monday an executive
from his media group says he's been
arrested on suspicion of colluding
with foreign powers we'll check in with
sarah clark for the latest now from
hong kong sarah tell us about well not
just jimmy
but the others have been arrested
welcome there's a sweeping police
operation underway uh we've got the
founder of apple daily which is a
pro-democracy media
outlet here in hong kong uh he's also
not considered a media tycoon jimmy lie
he's been arrested now he's been
arrested
under potential charges of violating the
new national security laws now at the
moment we have
a huge police search underway about 200
police are at the uh headquarters
of apple daily and they're conducting
searches on devices
interviewing those staff already there
and as you mentioned there are seven
people
have been arrested so far and we believe
some of those are senior staff
at the apple daily media network we also
have reports that two of his sons jimmy
ly's sons
have been arrested now i should say
they're not affiliated with apple daily
but we believe
been charged we could potentially be
charged for violations of company
business codes
so that could mean that uh the police
are investigating some of jimmy lye's
investments as well now as you mentioned
seven people arrested but all are under
suspicion
of violating these new national security
laws and we believe the staff
actually at the headquarters have been
told they can't leave while this police
search is underway so a sweeping
operation currently undergoing or
underway at the apple daily headquarters
here in hong kong on monday jimmy lai
has been arrested
before he's he's no stranger to this
sort of thing
but given this is happening under the
national security law for the first time
how might it be different sarah what
penalties could he face
well the charges under the new national
security laws are very different and
much tougher than the current charges
he's facing he's been was arrested in
february early this year
accused of participating in an
unauthorized assembly
last year he was also arrested or
charged with a legal assembly
uh for gathering at uh the victoria park
for the tiananmen square anniversary
this year but
monday's arrests and the potential
charges that he could face
under the national security law are much
tougher some of those
penalties could involve life in prison
now the national security law it targets
acts of secession
subversion terrorism and collusion with
foreign
powers and that's what he's been
investigated for now mr lye has
previously said
that he believes that the new law would
target him
the state run or the chinese-run media
operation the global times has said that
they have evidence or they have experts
who suggest
uh there is evidence from jimmy lie's
tweets suggesting he's been involved
with acts of subversion so clearly uh
the police are acting on that but if he
does face those charges
they will be tough penalties as a result
okay we'll check in with you again later
sarah to see if there's been any more
development sarah clark is in hong kong
we've also heard from emily law
chairperson at the international affairs
committee of the hong kong democratic
party who says this development
is having a chilling effect on the
city's journalists
well of course many hong kong people
woke up this morning
to learn of the news and many are
shocked
and horrified including myself and i
think this
is sent out a very very negative message
and of course it must have a chilling
effect
on people who want to speak out and
particularly
on the news media so this is a very very
disturbing
development although may maybe not
unexpected
but i and people say that hong kong no
longer has the rule of law so i hope
that jimi lai
and those other people who have been
arrested
will be able to have their rights
protected
and of course if the authorities have
evidence i hope they will come up with
it
because such allegations have been made
for a long time
and and up to now they have a deuce no
evidence
i think that we have seen quite a or
increasing
amount of self-censorship amongst the
news media
some local media even say that maybe
there are some foreign politicians
that they may not or should not
interview and
there are stories they should not write
and also their editors
may be telling them what to do and what
not to do
and also with academics uh with
political commentators
uh with people in political circle in
professional circle
so there is this you know reign of
terror people are very very worried and
don't know when they will be next